coming from the ussr having an enormous
amount of skepticism
towards authority is something that i
was taught at an extremely young age
what's the biggest aspect of your
philosophy they get pushed back
anarchism can be reduced to one sentence
you do not speak for me if there were
no government monopoly on police you
would be uh raped and murdered
immediately
oj simpson is a good example even today
if i'm rich i have better lawyers i'm
going to be able to get away with a lot
more than a poor person will
those who are driven by power get money
i think history tells us they have a
tendency of destroying a lot of things
what are your thoughts
just because someone was elected to
office the claim
that they should have some kind of say
over your life is bizarre
if not nonsensical my biggest concern
is the status quo where bill gates can
get the president
on the phone in a second i'm in favor of
abolishing the government police
monopoly so you partially are in favor
of defunding the police
you have to get it out of your head that
anarchism
is no law and order anarchism is the
mother of order
[Music]
my guest today everything he says it's
non-controversial
he's very much of a guy that likes to
follow the rules
he he is not a fan of ruffling the
feathers
he's always walking on eggshells worried
about hurting other people's feelings i
mean i don't know what other way to
tell you about my guest today it's
michael malus he's a free
speech proponent he's a anarchy
philosophies and a lot of other
philosophies that mainstream
uh folks are not big fans of he's
written a book
out of everybody you could have written
a book about he decides to write a book
about
kim young ill because he was in north
korea for a week
and he's got a lot of other great
stories i have a feeling you're going to
really enjoy this interview with that
being said michael thank you so much for
being a guest somebody tayman
i'm really really really uh irrationally
excited about this
irrationally excited about this so here
we go so
so most people think i'm a jew but you
actually
you know we started the conversation
that way yeah i mean i got the full-on
you at least have a nice note it's
mind-blowing well i got i got my taken
care of oh you know dude
now now i can pass i don't have your
kind of money i also got uncircumcised
you did twice what what what inspired
you to do that
was it like a a compliment from a female
was it what was it what influenced you
to do that
i just i guess i don't get along too
well with my family
to heck with this i'm gonna be a [ __ ] now
so so michael walk me through this like
in your family you're you're from a
good-sized family right i mean yeah you
guys
know how my parents are my parents are
both only children
both of them are yeah okay so it's not
the typical
typical family that you got a lot of
cousins you got a lot of no no no
so your family really is your mom your
dad and yourself
well grandma and my sister but they're
not all
on speaking terms so it's there's not
gonna be much of a reunion so
is that is that a genetic genetic thing
is the family pretty
they're always debating arguing like
what was it like growing
in the malice family i'm curious i
wasn't very nice um i think a lot of
people who have a russian background
will uh appreciate that it is not
very um conducive towards children
thriving
there's a lot of like any and this isn't
extreme in my family situation nor is it
unique to my family situation
but in you know russian households any
kind of
uh tenderness or kindness are used as
opportunities for uh harm
and anytime you i mean you laugh but you
think about this as a kid you know it
gets to your mother
from baku so you have to know that yeah
oh yeah exactly
like i was raised around the russian
culture so i relate compliment
yeah you do get a compliment you should
take a note and document it
because it may never happen again and
right and there's also
the concept that when something
potentially exciting happens to you
you're a businessman i don't need to
tell you how many times you had a
meeting
it went great second meeting goes great
nothing comes of it
having that good first meeting or like
having a good first date
even if nothing comes of it is still fun
and exciting you know whatever
but in a russian household as soon as
you're like oh i met this girl or
i had a job interview don't get your
hopes up blah blah blah
and that mentality i think is very very
sinister
and it's very un-american in in a bad
sense
and it also is you know my family still
can't wrap their heads around my last
book the anarchist handbook was the top
non-fiction book in all of amazon i was
out selling randos like barack obama and
oprah winfrey right
the point is my family still doesn't
understand
how i can pay the rent if i don't go to
an office it makes literally no sense to
them
so it's i do not have a good
relationship with my family at all
and it takes a long time for any of us
i'm sure you have similarities you know
with an iranian background it's that's
no cakewalk
to realize oh this isn't normal
or conducive to life this is really bad
and i have to do work to kind of
uh fix it and what do you think about
that what do you think like is your
desires to uh uh find a way to get
everybody together is it
i'm hopeless it's never gonna happen is
it we'll see what's gonna happen
is it i've tried a million times it's
just not gonna happen they're too
stubborn
how do you feel about the future of the
family coming together
there's zero hope nor desire and i'll
give you no no you i'll give you an
exactly what happened
on july 12 2010 my mentor
harvey picard died on my birthday right
and which was not fun i can assure you
as
i'm sure many people can imagine yeah
and one of the points i always make
is i don't judge people by their
political views
like i don't care i judge someone if
something bad happens in my family
and i make that call are you gonna be
what do you need or you know that's all
that matters that's
the mark of a good relationship so
seeing the reactions that i had at home
when you know harvey died on that day
was very very telling
and the point is and i don't just mean
my family mean friends as well
if you're not going to be there for me
today
well i i don't need you at a party
there's no shortage of people i can be
friendly with at a party like
for me the measure of a person in a
relationship is when
stuff hits the fan are they going to be
a reliable resource to make things
better for you
and can you reciprocate you know i want
to be of value to my friends and
uh associates and things like that i
want their lives to be better
as a result of having known me because
what better compliment can you tell
about a person
than that he or she uh uh increases the
thriving of everyone around them
this person's amazing and we all have
that capacity to some extent to be that
person now let me ask you i grew up in a
family my mother's side their bible was
karl marx communist manifesto they're my
mother's side
my dad's side they're imperialist they
love the shop iran so it's i mean
my parents got a divorce twice in 20
years so it's very obvious and proven
you should probably not get married to
another person who's an imperialist or a
communist
mathematically it's going to fail but
i'm glad they got married because i came
after the second time they got married
and it was kind of like let's try to
make it work and boom
what were your parents political beliefs
and what kind of influence did that have
on you
growing up uh that's a great question i
think when you are raised
in a soviet household uh you know we
spoke russian at home and had that
mindset
in in i mean i came here when i was two
in another country
you're going to perceive things in a
very different light
than things that people who grew up in a
culture country or culture take for
granted
there's this um analogy of two fish are
in a river
and one says oh the water's really warm
today and the other one goes what's
water
right because when we're in an
environment for 100 of the time we
become oblivious that that's the
environment
as opposed to just think it's the world
or the norm so
uh having an enormous amount of
skepticism
towards authority is something that i
was taught at an extremely young age
uh you know coming from the ussr the
idea that
journalists or politicians have any kind
of uh
correlation to the truth is not only
false but just
a joke you know obviously the soviet
union is
way way way more extreme and worse than
the west
uh and let's make that perfectly clear
pravda in the new york times i have my
issues in new york times
but this is in many ways night and day
um both as a function new york times and
puncture the culture surrounding the new
york times and our liberal democracy
but things like that things like having
veneration
towards agents of the state uh is
something that was completely foreign to
my thinking
uh things like believing that everyone
matters
and has something to contribute is
something that was foreign to my
thinking
um that every human being is special so
those are just kind of things that uh
are just i was raised and have grown to
reaffirm as an adult
um that i was taught as a kid that would
be very different to american ears
now let me ask you when you ask your
parents mom dad why do we leave
where we left what did they tell you
like why do why do we come to america
why do we come
because can i curse of course yeah so
because russia's a [ __ ] and it's
also
people in this country who complain
about racism and all these other isms
are given your background i need to tell
you this are completely oblivious
to the amounts of prejudice and
oppression and repression in other parts
of the world
uh to be jewish in the soviet union you
are never going to go a day
that goes by when you're not reminded of
this you know my dad
would tell me the story of how he was in
college and a college professor
who you know we tend to think of as
educated and informed
and kind of uh uh classical liberal put
his hand on my dad's shoulder and told
him
you're one of the good ones so it's the
kind of thing where
it's this is unimaginable to americans
that a professor
would say something like this and
genuinely trying to be complimentary
whereas you know it's it's just really
uh um you know you're very kind of
condescending and offensive
at a certain point they're like why do i
need this like let's create a better
life for my son which
they were instrumental in doing and i am
extremely grateful
for them you know i'm a huge patriot
uh and i love this country i hate the
government because i love this country
i hate the government because i love
this country yeah let me let me ask you
this question
your parents they come they're you know
you came here at two so they were their
college they grew up you know jobs all
that other stuff they experienced but
you come over here
what part of political beliefs do you
agree with them
and which part do you guys clash in uh
we weren't talking politics when i was a
kid much obviously
when you're here like i'm talking you
become i'm talking about the 18 year old
michael
now you i'm assuming you have strong
opinions what parts did you say
i agree with them what part did you
clash with
uh i never really talked politics at
home there were no clashes
um my parents both have this very uh
cynical sepsis and view toward the state
uh not to the extent that i do
but i can't think of anything where
there would be a clash and i
i i find it hard to empathize although i
sympathize
with people who go home for thanksgiving
and for
and they haven't seen mom or dad in a
while and it becomes a political debate
that is so contrary to my constitution
and how if i'm going on a trip right
i don't want strife with my loved ones
i want to catch up oh you this is your
hobby tell me about your hobby
this is my job this is who i'm dating so
on and so forth
there's enough of that nonsense on
twitter and i don't engage in it i'm not
big on
arguments uh i'm big on shutting down
discourse
so that i can't think of anything
where that there was a big conflict
about
politics at all if and even if they
disagreed it would be like
okay you're just a dumb kid like
tongue-in-cheek but
you know like hahaha but it wasn't like
uh
they were offended or there was some
kind of drama that's great to hear i
mean i agree it's very great i'm blessed
in that regard
no question about it because sometimes
you know it's it's uh i've seen the
opposite and it can be pretty ugly
when you see the complete opposite of
that and it's so needlessly ugly
it's like if this is your kid and the
question to me
is is this person happier thriving right
i have many friends i'm an anarchist
most of my friends don't agree with me
many of my friends i don't know what
their politics are why would i care like
i've got a friend
this is what he does this is when he was
his spare time this is how he treats his
wife this is what we talk about at
dinner
it makes no difference to me uh if
they're pro-life
pro-death penalty pro-iraq war i mean we
could talk about it because this is my
job
but it in no way is it going to affect
my impression of them as a person the
only way would it matter
is they insisted on talking about it
constantly
in which case it's like this isn't going
to work because i talk about
professionally
i just want to hang out and relax
interesting so when the when the
when the when you take off the hat off
you know what you're doing
professionally podcasts all these other
things
you kind of want to just kick back and
just talk life rather than talk about
what you talk about
uh on your podcast politics and and the
other thing is when you're talking to
friends who this isn't their job right
like anyone who's a professional like
you're talked about my north korea book
what happens is if you're at an event
and you know what oh you're an author
what kind of books you write my book was
on north korea
and they start just for some reason they
have this spontaneous need to tell me
everything that they know about north
korea
it's like it's okay that you know
nothing this is not you know how
what are the colors in a street light
this is the most cryptic hidden country
on earth
i wrote the book because then you could
be informed
but if you know nothing that's perfectly
fine there's lots of things i know
nothing about and if i meet an author of
that i'll be like oh that's interesting
or not but that doesn't reflect on my
character
as you know perfectly well and more
people should know the smartest person
is going to be ignorant of 99 of
knowledge doesn't mean they're
dumb they just means okay i didn't study
this and that's perfectly fine
there's so much out there to learn no
question about it so michael give me
your
philosophies you say i'm an antarctic
tell me tell me your core like i believe
in this i don't believe in this i
believe in this i believe in this just
kind of walk me through it
okay anarchism can be reduced to one
sentence no you do not speak
you do not speak for me everything else
is application
okay so that's the there's your your
elevator pitch answer in one
second in terms of morals i think it's
just a function of
uh integrity living according to your
values
uh be a resource to your allies
uh and surround yourself with people who
are making it happen
because not only is luck rub off on you
but i am so glad that i have friends who
are
have made it because if i'm having a
personal problem
maybe they're not in my industry but
they're still dealing with similar
problems then you could pick the phone
and now they're delighted and i'm sure
you are with your friends it's like
i've been dealing with this crap for
years i figured things out
fine now i can ameliorate your headaches
and suffering
by just giving you 30 seconds of my time
so that's kind of the
mindset i'm working with what's the
biggest uh area
of aspect of your philosophy they get
pushed back with which part of it
oh if there were no government monopoly
on police you would be
raped and murdered immediately and what
do you think about that
why don't i have a gun why can't i hire
a bodyguard
why can't i get a security system it's a
very bizarre
and if someone's coming to break in my
house right now
the cops aren't gonna do anything anyway
how am i getting to the phone so it's a
very um weird scenario they construct
because the
the argument is apparently under an
anarchist system
all combat is one-on-one and weapons
don't exist
got it so for what you believe in you
you don't believe in defunding the
police you just believe we don't need
cops right
well we don't need a government monopoly
on cops you certainly need security
but in the same way that if the
government didn't produce clothing we
wouldn't all be naked
uh if you didn't have a monopoly and any
monopoly if you have a monopoly on a
product it's always going to be
delivered
inefficiently poorly and almost
inevitably at the cost of human life
whereas if you had choice and if you had
options
you would have innovation and you would
have solutions
instead of having a system where the
problems are perpetuated
uh for the sake of those in power so
if you have an anarchy you don't have a
government that has a monopoly on cops
right which means they control that but
if you have an anarchy
in an anarchy what does the government
look like how limited is it or is it not
there's no there's no government that's
what anarchy means
so if there's no government and
everybody is everybody is running under
give me an example of when that worked
effectively anarchy
when you returned a sweater to the
department store
when you returned the sweater to the
department store yes
you had a conflict neither of you is in
a position of authority over one another
and the conflict was resolved amicably
and peacefully in seconds
now if i'm involving the government and
there's a conflict i have to
pay a lawyer which is exorbitant going
to cost more than a surgeon
and the outcome will be uncertain but
we're certain of it's going to take a
very long time
so that is one difference between how
the market saw and freedom
solves for disputes as opposed to having
it go through the state i guess what i'm
asking is give me a country that had a
system of anarchy that did very well for
you know a handful of decades
first of all you're not going to have an
anarchist country by definition right
second of all i can give you several
examples like medieval iceland and
medieval ireland which had it for a
thousand years far longer the
constitution
i don't think that's a valid question
for several reasons one is
just because it worked in iceland and
ireland doesn't mean it's going to work
in 2021
and just because it hasn't happened
anywhere previously doesn't mean it's
going to be working in 2021 either
one example of this is the internet
right before the internet if you sat
down and posited the internet
it would sound maybe if not crazy
certainly hard to wrap your head around
we would have no idea what websites
would look like but at the same time
this something ended up happening has
now become a universal faction of
human life so anarchism isn't a location
it's a relationship
and it simply means that one of the or
that none of the parties
claims authority or has authority over
one another
so every country on earth right now is
in a state of energy toward one another
every country right now in the world
right now is a state of anarchy towards
one another
everything in the world right as a state
of canada okay
um so let's go let's go a little bit
deeper so
meaning there's not going to be a
country with anarchy because if there's
anarchy there is no country so there
means there's no borders
there is no so then how do you deal with
property how do you deal with ownership
how do you deal with community how do
you deal with
is there laws and regulations in the
world that you visualize is there laws
and regulations there
there will be certainly rules and for
example if i am part of a
gated community right there are certain
rules that i have chosen to by living
there
uh um ascribe to and for example macy's
the earlier example
macy's has many grounds on which i can't
enter the store
if i'm not wearing shirts if i'm not
wearing shoes if i can't
if i'm blasting music so what it would
do is to it would maximize freedom and
everyone who has
dominion over their own property would
be the one setting those rules uh as he
or she
sees fit how security will be provided
is the same way that fashion would be
provided you would have
many different outlets uh selling their
wares and whoever wanted to
what people another common criticism is
like what if you're poor
right and then you can't afford security
you're just gonna get killed on the
street
well security look at look at a bar
right a bar is filled with young
drunk males full of testosterone often
itching for a fight
there's no cop there but there's a
bouncer and the bouncer's job is to make
sure
that things don't get out of hand and
the bouncer's job is to make sure that
some people can't even get in to begin
with
and to keep the proportions of the
genders in the bar at a certain level
if you had a private society uh security
wouldn't be a function
necessarily of the individual you would
also have security over
areas just like you have at macy's
eurobar right now
and the problem is when the government
monopoly is in charge security
that is where crime is allowed to happen
and if you think about the places you're
most likely to be the victim of an
assault
it's things like alleyways streets the
subway
all areas where the government monopoly
is in charge of security
whereas if you think of a place like a
bar or a hotel where everyone is a
stranger to that area and is
not going to be able to be tracked down
too easily those are much safer
uh than public venues yeah so
so then then the priority of what things
you have to get good at if it's anarchy
with no government
self-defense becomes a very high
priority
why why wouldn't it because if if i have
a non-regulatory environment without a
law and order
you have order order based on who though
based on community
right based on individuals not based on
sure and i don't have to agree with the
order that you come up with because my
set of orders may be different than
yours no
correct correct so then so then the part
becomes
if we're living on two sets of orders i
don't have to be a loyalist to your set
of orders
so our order may clash and if our orders
clash then how the hell do we
cooperate how do we have what happens
right now
if i rear-end you and we have different
insurance companies i the first thing
you do is i ask you for your license you
ask me for your money
for mine right you look there's a
mechanism right there's a man i get for
drivers
if you run off i take a picture a
driver's license let's just say but you
say hey can we work this out great
here's my insurance card and we exchange
information
right the the the possibility that it
gets violent
sometimes happens people get hot-headed
my god my ferrari
but when you say over 99 of the time
even if it's antagonistic it's not
reaching the point where violence is
escalating that oh
we see car accidents all the time it
never becomes violent or
or deadly and that's not simply a
function of oh i'm going to go to jail
it's because i just want this resolved i
want to get out of my life i hate this
guy
i want him out of my sight this would be
the exact same principle applied
on a person or location basis you would
have your security agency
i would have mine we have a dispute if
you want to go to fisticuffs just like
right now
i can't really stop you i mean although
i would be armed
on the other hand what we could do is i
hate you pat
i hate you michael we're gonna let our
security people take care of it and
they're gonna take the steps as
appropriate
what if i don't have the money to pay my
security people
well that's that's what if you don't
have the money to pay for car insurance
what happens then
what you know the difference is if i pay
for
car insurance the cost isn't as much as
me needing to like car insurance i can
do it for 60 bucks 100 bucks 150
bucks i'm sure still i'm still uh
uh look you got to realize i'm i'm uh
i'm more on your side i'm just trying to
break it apart like for me let me
let me tell you how i am like uh my kids
play outside the other day my kids
climbed on top of the house
and let me tell you this house like i
don't even know what the hell they did
my wife says baby you have to see this
my wife is 38 and a half weeks pregnant
she says come take a look at what they
did so i'm like babe
these guys melva showed it to me my
nanny they walked to the second floor
they open the door and you know in our
house when a door open thing thing you
hear the sound yeah yeah the door's open
so they go
up they climb on top of the ceiling
they're 30 feet
up and then they come back down and
everyone's panicking
and i say babe what are you going to do
about it i mean honestly
you think we tell them don't do it do
something they're going to do it so i'm
more
i'm the guy that you know my my wife and
my nanny they walk the dogs with leashes
i like to walk the dogs and we just kind
of you know figure out don't get me
wrong if i had a german shepherd or a
pitbull
i probably cannot do that but i'm more
leaning towards i let's let's kind of
give you a little bit more freedom so
you're willing to be more loyal to me
than hey come here you better do this so
i'm leaning towards that side
but there's also part of it where who
wins in a situation like that whoever
has more money
like even today that's but that's the
current status see
the what are presented is the strongest
sorry to interrupt you when are
presented as the strongest arguments are
against anarchism are inevitably
descriptions of status quo
even today if i'm rich o.j simpson is a
good example
i have better lawyers i'm going to be
able to get away with a lot jeffrey
epstein's another one
i'm going to be able to get away with a
lot more than a poor person will
this concept of equality under the law
makes no sense if you think about it for
five seconds
under the law rich people and powerful
people are always going to have access
to both
reputation so they're going to be
regarded better by the jury or possibly
worse if the jury has an animus against
rich and powerful people
but the very least i will have access to
better lawyers
now the law there's an essay in the book
by uh hasness who is a georgetown law
professor
uh called the myth of objective law and
he points out this concept that law
can be applied objectively makes no
sense even for three seconds if you
think about it
the law is always inevitably subject to
interpretation
and it is the job of lawyers as a class
and this is a condemnation of lawyers
to take what is written in plain english
and to
twist it so it forces the result that
your client regards as desirable
so these are all problems that at the
very very very very least
are extremely expensive and time
consuming
and this demonstrates if you ask someone
how often had you had a problem
with someone on ebay how often you had a
problem with starbucks or macy's or a
friend
and how often you had a lawsuit if
lawsuits were an effective mechanism of
adjudicating disputes
then people will be doing a lot more
frequently in the same way that they
return their clothes very frequently
because it'd be something that's like
okay even if i lose
i'm going to have my answer within a day
or two as now
you're losing years of your life and
tens of thousands of dollars
what to which makes it not a possibility
for most people
in terms of adjudicating and solving
disputes which is something we all
desperately need
michael you think uh uh most people have
good intentions
i don't think most people have minds so
they don't have good or bad intentions
they're they're working on an animal
level
so you don't think most people have mind
okay so let's go based on that if you
don't
believe most people are mine what
percentage of people you think are
emotional
and irrational i don't wouldn't say
irrational i would say non-rational
because
irrational is like a crazy person who's
acting erratically
uh they act in predictable patterns but
they're they've been treated
they have either lacked the capacity or
had it been trained out of them in
in schooling and in the media to uh
for stall critical thought as a as a
individual
let's just say there's the four
different types of personalities those
who are
extremely structured organized those who
are extremely technical analytical
those who are extremely action oriented
ambitious and those who are all about
relationship
love which one of those four would you
put yourself as
structure or a second one technical
analytical yeah
okay i i would agree with you that
you're technical analytical okay
uh would you say you are a pretty
independent guy are you an independent
yes
okay you're 1976 july something right
you're you're a 1976 person we're two
years apart
i'm 42 i don't know you you're about to
turn
you're about to turn 45. i'm about to
turn 43 in a couple months i'm after you
right
but we're right next to each other
age-wise same age we are
yeah you know a long time ago and i want
you to
tear apart my argument your what i'm
about to tell you long time ago i'm 25
26 years old and you know i'm like dad i
believe
anybody can have their dreams become a
reality and i'm an optimist and i just
feel like that's like stop it i'm like
no
so you know this guy comes at the hound
to the house and you know every time he
sees this guy the guy's gained 10 more
pounds 10 more pounds 10 more pounds
over a span of like a you know five
years that guy gains 80 pounds one of my
friends he gains 80 pounds right
and he says it's because of business you
know we work so hard and i put on 80
pounds
and i'm like but i believe he can change
i believe he gets one of my best friends
i believe he can change i believe he can
change
and we have this clash my my dad and i
he finally says
do you think everybody is as independent
as you are you think everybody can go
you know survive for themselves and be
independent some people
need to be led and managed and you know
directed to go some people need rules
and regulations and guidelines some
people need eight to five some people
need
uh that that part being in place some
people don't so so the part becomes do
you think sometimes you think
because you would exist in a anarchy
type of nmr you and i probably would be
fine
but do you think everybody else is like
you
no god no um but and and that's why i
don't think i should be living on their
terms by the way what you just said i
agree with everything
that doesn't make them a bad person no i
never thought you were bad no i just
want to be clear for them
not your friend it's not of course i
think a lot of people
who are maybe wired like you and i see
someone who needs rules and regulations
and tend to be dismissive or
contemptuous of them it's like no no
this is how this person's wired
and you pat and me are going to be
extremely
frustrated if you believe what we're
taught at school that everyone thinks
the same
and everyone's wired the same that is
completely inaccurate
and just because they're wired
differently doesn't mean bad things
should happen to them
or they shouldn't thrive this is just
their path but neither does it mean
that just because there's a lot of
people who are like your friend
that should have any kind of impetus or
impact i don't know why i just said
impetus
any kind of impact on me and my uh
personal choices and preferences
it seems like every podcast i've been
doing i've been using the same quote but
it's such a good one h.l mencken who
if people don't know who he is should
really look him up he was a great uh
newspaper man in the early 20th century
the one the first
american wits he had the quote that the
average man does not want to be free he
merely wants to be safe
and i think we see that constantly
oh i mean how can you not believe that
you just say just like your friend you
said he he needs his rules and
regulations he doesn't want choices how
does he average man then survive in an
anarchy
well i'm not i'm concerned about me and
i'm concerned about the above average
now in an anarchy they it would be same
thing here they would
just higher security they would not be a
target because they're not sticking out
they're going to their jobs they're
coming home they're watching big bang
theory
uh they're upset by things that they're
told to be upset about and they go to
bed
and they would have perfectly healthy
peaceful lives
yeah so you said i'm concerned about me
not the other person
not that type of person correct type of
person but in an anarchy what is the
responsibility of you
being concerned about others zero right
it's not just like
just like just like in the just like in
real life
just like in real life just like now i i
haven't i wish your friend well
yeah but he has no claim on my person
what i didn't even know he existed
you have any kids not yet okay uh
yeah i mean you know
philosophically i'm on your side
philosophically
i live by what you say like i don't need
anybody to help me i gotta i'm gonna do
my part but at the same time
i know if i want to do something big i
need the help of others because i'm sure
i need all this other stuff right right
of course and
but to to say like if i if i was to put
everybody in the same room together
let's just say we put 100 people in the
room and we're gauging you against 100
other people
you're probably going to be in the top
one percentile or whatever number that
we use
sure for intelligence and technical and
anal analytical you're going to be
you're going to school the hell out of
everybody right which means
okay you'll probably be able to maneuver
better find a
better solution you'll probably be
better at synchronizing your
at what stage of sequencing your next
five 10 15 moves versus another person
i don't know what to do you know what i
just like michael i follow michael where
are we going right
but then if i said hey we're going to do
a fist fight you may be like dude i
don't know if i want to do a fistfight
i'm not in the top one percent but
there's
there's just one big guy that's just
fake and books
you may lose in that area so yeah i
definitely lose yeah so so all i'm
saying is
it makes sense but brother the the
strong
people who are driven by ego and extreme
but there's 99 of there's 99 of us and
one of him why am i fighting him
one-on-one
why don't i have a gun why can't i hire
a bigger guy okay so in your environment
you would be okay with having guns
everybody so second amendment everyone
can have a gun
whatever you want to do you can have a
gun of course okay so in anarchy
everybody would
own a gun so let's just if they wanted
to they not everyone have one they'd
have the ability to get one but maybe
not even true
because there's certainly it's certainly
possible that gun stores would say
you'd have a rep on ebay right you have
a reputation store right yeah
so if you have a certain rating you
might have a card and this gun store
will say
unless you have a certain reputational
score that you can demonstrate to me
i don't feel comfortable selling you
firearms and that's the case now
i'm not a gun owner but if you go to gun
stores by and large they're very
cognizant of the dangers of what they're
selling
and they do want to create a peaceful
community and not just
uh you know warfare michael how do you
handle ownership like i own my car
that's my car in an anarchy that's my
house that's my land
how do i manage for you to not come and
take it away from it
say what's stopping me now the rules and
uh laws in order law and order
no not really like if i could if i could
go to let's pretend i'm at your house
right now
before no i but let me give you an
example i'm at your house right now
there's books behind you
i am sure that uh if i could if i was
there i could take one of those books
and you wouldn't know
or if you did know how are you going to
get it back right sure it would never
enter my head
now let's talk about bigger things let's
suppose i could somehow steal your house
right and not uh somehow get away
or your car is an easier one because
cars are portable you would have a
security uh
your either your insurance or your
security company their job
would be to return the car something the
police are completely incapable of doing
and don't even pretend to have an
interest in doing ask anyone who's ever
been burglarized
the cops show up they there's not if you
have sitcoms
right even in sitcoms where everything's
completely imaginary
when a character is robbed and the cops
show up the cops don't even pretend
they're going to get your stuff back
they're like oh we'll take down a report
and nothing ever happens even this
completely imaginary world
let's so let's talk about anarchism i go
and i steal your car
well either your insurance provider or
your security provider
would for a fee return that car to you
or
you they would uh pay you back in terms
of like having a homeowner's insurance
uh and that is how the different firms
would compete unlike now
where you have a government monopoly and
the government monopoly doesn't even
pretend
to provide you the service that you're
paying much more money than you would be
paying
to a private firm like a bounty hunter
so to me
okay let me let me respond to that so to
me i i live in life of odds
and here's what i mean by odds you're
sitting with somebody and you want to
marry somebody like
let me tell you um you got one too many
boyfriends
you know how you're sitting across the
table and you're not saying you're just
thinking you're like
yeah yeah yeah i'm you told me you've
been with 10 guys i'm going to bed you
probably went a lot more a couple times
you were drunk and i don't know who
those guys are hopefully you've not been
with anybody i know maybe if you have
what i ever know about it and
have you ever done this have you ever
kissed a girl have you ever folded on
with that
how bad of a money issue do you have
let's just say sexually transmitted
disease that
you're calculating all this stuff yeah
your temper but
yeah you never tell the other person but
we do and she says
i don't know about you right now you
seem a little reckless and you're a
little too close to your exes in the
past and they always call you and your
mom is this and your dad is a
i don't know that's a little you know
what i think there's a 40 chance this
marriage is going to work out screw it
let's do it right so
yeah right correct so so for me i
think of odds and that's how i'm wired
you stealing a
book without me knowing about it great
but if you take it and say i'm taking
this book
sure i can say [ __ ] to this guy he's
more powerful than me okay go ahead so
that's an
aspect of bullying right so but the guy
that's a criminal like you know how they
say send me the world gravana once told
me look you can take guns from good
people
no matter who you take guns away from i
promise you a bad person
i'm still going to have a gun there's
nothing you can do about bad people
having guns and criminals
having guns he's right wait can i say
one more thing that's important here
yeah
not only is he going to have guns he's
going to have friends in the police
department who are going to make sure he
doesn't get trouble
sure and and again i think yes too
but the part i go to is when you're
sitting there
sitting there you're like i'm gonna i'm
gonna steal this guy's car let's just
say
i get caught in today if i get caught
i'm going to be facing three years in
jail i got a kid at the house so i
really want to do it ah you know what
i was thinking about it i'm not there's
a lot of things in our lives we were
about to do
that were stupid thought maybe you
haven't but many of us sure know i
absolutely i'm about to do something
real stupid and in your mind you're like
you know what no i'm going to move on
right so
that's the part where i think law and
order eliminates maybe
10 percent of crimes and stupidity
uh it's quite the opposite what you are
calling first of all it's not order at
all
but what you're calling law in fact
encourages this kind of behavior
and i'll give you one good example uh if
if
you had a credit score like ebay or
something like that or your
ipad period whatever whatever account
for your credit cards
um that right is a chance
they ca there's different not only is
that the market provide at least three
credit firms
so they each have different mechanisms
that tells me and i can look up mine and
you can look up yours
what are the odds if i lend this guy
money
yeah historically based on his past
behavior
that he's going to repay it that he's a
good risk it's always going to be a risk
it's never 100 even if it's bill gates
and it's never zero percent right now if
you
are a car robber and have been arrested
and i go you come in for my company and
i interview you
it is illegal now for me to ask you
if you've ever gone to jail and
committed crimes so i have
no way of running a background check
whereas in a free society
these kinds of things that you've done
will follow you
around for quite a long time i don't
think jail is a very big deterrent
but i think reputation is a much
stronger determinant deterrent and a
much more peaceful deterrent
uh um than something like the threat of
three years in jail because a lot of
these criminals know perfectly well
that they're not going to be doing much
time and if they are doing time they
don't really care about it
okay partially agree on the jail side
because there's a lot of people nowadays
that are wanting to go to jail because
it's a lot better
and their friends are there sure but the
difference is you probably wouldn't like
to go to jail you
you probably wouldn't like to yeah i
think i think the odds of that are 100
yeah so the point
to the point is but that gets a guy like
you to say you know what
you don't know it doesn't well i
wouldn't i'm not thinking of robbing
your car except for jail that's not i
don't even know how to drive
yeah but okay so maybe maybe not okay so
let me give you a different example here
my mother
and her brother late brother her brother
just died a couple years ago god bless
his soul
he always brought me caviar late at
night and we have great i love caviar
you know i grew up on caviar i used to
make fun of me in elementary school
i'm a diet probably there's so much fish
eggs in my body i i'm probably semi-fish
right now i don't know but
so so you're pregnant one of those two
i'm definitely pregnant with fish
somewhere in there but
you know my my great grandfather
was very well-off okay he was the only
one on my mother's side that was not a
communist
he was a worker and they all were like
yeah but but but
and he wanted everybody to work but they
kind of like oh grandpa's so rich he had
a nice house waterfront all this other
stuff
that he earned that he earned he earned
earned make that clear yes
so then he dies okay money goes to his
kids
and then my grandfather my grandmother
the money from there
gets rolled down and they're about to uh
they die
and that money that gets passed down
gets passed down to
my mom's brother uncle it's about a half
a million u.s dollars which in iran it's
a lot of money it's in your
lot of money but in iraq it's a lot of
money my uncle
was a very strong personality physical
man that pushed his weight around was a
boxer
like you did not want to mess with this
he was a tough guy he was a bootlegger
back in the days that's how i made his
money because bootlegging was illegal in
iran
still still did it so it was a business
model my mom never saw
a pen penny of that money right there
because he just said i'm not going to
give it to you i'll take care of you but
i'm not going to give it to you
there's nothing my mother could do to
get my
the money from my uh
uncle because it's like what are you
gonna do about it it's my money
say something do something so i think
naturally
there will be a lot of people that will
be abused by those
you remember back in the days that would
make fun of capitalists and they would
show all capitalist pictures as what you
know those pictures are fat guys
yeah yeah and now these capitalists are
like six-pack cut up like [ __ ]
i thought capitalists were supposed to
be fat lazy you know guys that just took
the money and they went around and there
used to be a time where that was the
case
was like just money being passed down in
the next month so hey you better not do
this or else
so people know how to kind of throw
their weight and bully the little guy
my concern is in an environment like
that it may give birth to a lot of
bullies what do you think
that is the status quo you're describing
pretty much not only every politician
but the behavior of the vast majority of
low status people during the lockdowns
which gave them an excuse to assert
dominance and rank over those who they
were told and regarded as their
subordinates and inferiors number one
number two is you don't want that bully
uh
which would 100 exist under anarchism
let me make that clear
what you're describing is a personality
type it has been here for thousands of
years
they probably wrote about in the old
testament they're going to be writing
about in 4
000 years that's not changing i i'm not
one of the your communist
relatives have the complete delusion
that if they structure society a certain
way it's going to change
human nature and not only make them
change but it's also going to make them
uniform this is completely
nonsensical if you look at a dog litter
you're going to have different
personalities there
so the claim that some a mind as complex
as a human being
is all going to be able to think in the
same way it just makes no sense on any
level number one
what you would want is to have
power be as decentralized as possible
so that bully who is going to be drawn
to power in the same way that let's
suppose a musical theater graduate is
going to be drawn to broadway
you want to limit his capacity to be
able to enforce his will
on others and the way to do that is to
maximize
choice opportunity and competition which
is what freedom
allows under the current system there
are
very many mechanisms in america for this
guy and i'm not going to
talk about your uncle i don't want to
talk about your family let's suppose
your uncle on steroids just a really
jerk like a horrible human being you
wouldn't get along with him
there are so many venues right now
thanks to the state
where this person can put their will
into power
and have literally deadly consequences
i would want to return it to a situation
which is not utopia but certainly where
the worst thing this guy could do is
beat somebody up which is something
that's inevitable a big dude
will always have that capacity you're
not going to be able to take it away
unless you're literally living in the
matrix
so what i want to do is to minimize his
ability
to impose his will on large groups of
people and i don't think that's
necessarily a function of his size
i mean there's plenty of small dudes and
women who revel
in having that sense of domination and
authority over others
and i want to cut out the pull out the
rug from under them
yeah i mean anyone who's been married
knows perfectly well that it's not about
size in terms of who's going to be
dominating who necessarily i don't think
it's size i think it's a
i think it's an aura i think it's a
personality of the individual guys that
are nice guys and i know of course
the kindest nice small guys so uh uh
small guys are usually jerks much more
than big guys because we can get away
with it
yeah like this is what people don't
appreciate like they'll say oh andrew
can you get your ass kicked
it's a lot easier for me to shove a dude
i'm i'm five
uh whatever then if a six foot four guy
comes up to me at a bar and shoves me
he's in a lot of trouble because not
only is immediately everyone jumping on
him and pulling him away
good luck telling whatever the in this
case it would be the police in another
society would be a security system good
luck telling them that i started it
you're a 6-4 you have the obligation to
walk away uh
is how it tends to work sounds like you
have experience with that i don't know
if that's it
i don't i i actually have been so bad at
getting into fights i got
i made my friend do a fight club with me
so i know what it's like i had a guy
i had a sergeant of mine in the army
this guy was a freaking nutcase but i
loved him
we would go to bars he was five six
maybe 120 pounds on a good day
rain maybe 125. and he would go talk
[ __ ] to
everybody he would you [ __ ] i
dare you
throw a punch and all this others and
then he get into a fight and say
that's my friend right there and anyway
yeah i'm like
so we get into fights he would be out of
them like
this nutcase he got us in trouble all
the time but again until today i'm
friends with them and i love the guy
but it's also if you're looking look
just one more point if you look at dogs
it's the small ones that tend to be the
aggressive ones because they just
yeah yep i agree so so let me ask you a
question
give me a step pre-anarchy like let's
just say we're not gonna go full anarchy
hypothetically
because now i get the fact that you're
an anarchist you believe in that
the chances of that happen in america
anytime soon is slim to none of it
happening that
i think it's 100 that it's going to
happen yes okay
so before we go to the argument 100 with
me let me just make sure let me clarify
what i mean
by a hundred percent i don't mean that
the federal government is going to be
abolished
but i do think there is a 100 chance
within the next let's suppose 100 years
that there will be space for people to
live free without the threat of the
state
over their heads it doesn't have to be
all of america but that's not 100
anarchy though you're talking
well no it would be not worldwide but
i'm saying i get that so
so you're talking about are you talking
about like a john
galt iran type of a setting is that kind
of what you're thinking about
where they're going to create their own
uh a place where everybody kind of
leaves each other alone and
we don't have law and order we just
trust the fact that you're going to
improve i'm going to improve and we're
going to attract only people
like us you have to get it out of your
head
that anarchism is no law and order uh
anarchism is the mother of order when
people engage
voluntarily based on individuals it's
not based on a crime right
when people were so it's i would
probably awarded more
values and principles less law and order
right because this is a good example you
have a show
you invited me on we negotiated times we
negotiate how long it's going to take
the possibility of this getting violent
was literally zero uh we wish each other
well
and we came to mutual agreement so
there's many examples of day-to-day
basis
where people come to agreement and set
up and the rules is it's your show
and you run it like you want and if you
tell me to shut up i either shut up or
you cut me off or you hang up you know
whatever it is
you're the one who's in a position to
impose your rules but there's no real
law here whatsoever
it's something that we have
spontaneously and we do this on a
day-to-day basis with everyone we
encounter
have a mutually agreed upon negotiation
based on certain parameters that we also
mutually agree upon
yeah there's a big difference but this
is understanding mutual understanding
almost like a code that we live by
exactly
but but law and order is on paper i got
to follow that law
order in an anarchy there's not going to
be a law order it's going to be
mutual understandings that we have and
if i don't like the way you handle
yourself you and i are probably never
going to do business together and i'm
going to go my way you're going to go
your own way
so and we'll win and we'll wish each
other well so what comes before anarchy
what's before anarchy in your eyes a
libertarian
what is anarchy i i don't think it's a
gradual process i think it's going to be
somewhat of a binary process
but i think what needs to happen first
is a
increase in the skepticism and contempt
for the state and its actors so i think
when you're seeing
what's very healthy in this country as a
phenomenon especially on internet
circles
is enormous amount of skepticism if not
contempt toward corporate media
a recognition that just because someone
was elected to office the
the claim that they should have some
kind of say over your life or your
person is
bizarre if not nonsensical uh those are
two kind of and
also ending a very uh this is the one
i'm most excited about
and strongly increased skepticism
towards war
as a mechanism as resolving human
disputes i think we've seen that happen
in the last 20 years shift very very
hard and i'm very very excited to see
that happen michael you ever see this
when there's elections and you know
melissa milano will come out and say i
swear to god if trump gets elected i'm
leaving the country i'm going to canada
or i'm going this right or
hey you know another person comes out
and says hey if if biden gets elected
i'm leaving everybody says that stuff
from both sides
no no it's not both sides it's always
the democrats i would say 90
as democrats but i've heard people also
say it on the right side there are
people but they're
sure no they will it's just not bigger
names but people say there's no way i'm
staying here
believe me i live in florida i i look at
yachts going past my house
every single day a thousand of them
every day votes in yachts that go by
trump flag is 99 of the attempts to
trump flip
oh sure i'm sure but my point my point
is i i i think
there was an asymmetry in that the
people who disliked trump
disliked him a lot more than the people
who just like biden just like biden okay
so so the point where i'm going with
this part is this here's where i'm going
if you're an anarchy guy and right now
if i'm not mistaken you're still are you
in new york or you're not in new york
where
i i'm still in brooklyn i'm moving to
austin you're moving austin
you move into austin because austin
gives you a little bit more
feeling of what you're looking for over
new york or what i'm moving
i move first there's moving anywhere
when you've been somewhere all your life
is a very complex issue with lots of
degrees number one uh the fact that all
my friends are there
the fact that one of my dreams was as a
new yorker
was to have a townhouse because that's
when you're like you've really made it
you have a new york townhouse
austin has town houses i just learned
and they're a third the price
so it's like why am i new york has
gotten very very bad
it's only going to get worse there's no
mechanism for turning the ship around
the near future
and i was on uh lauren chen show she's a
canadian pundit
and she had her dad had cancer and under
canada's healthcare system during co but
he couldn't even get like like seen for
like a year or something absolutely
crazy
and she you know sometimes someone will
say a line and it's just matter-of-fact
and casual but it like it breaks your
brain
and she just said to me why am i funding
my own oppression
and i'm like holy crap lauren and i'm
like why am i staying here
and working hard and it's dirty and none
of my friends are here
and all the stores are like to be closed
down and i'm paying a lot of taxes
what have i got to show for it you know
given the kind of careers you and i have
and what you talk about in your work
freedom means
you know what this place sucks i'm out
of here and that is something i
feel very privileged to have this is
something that very few people on earth
have
and i'm absolutely going to take
advantage of it and and a lot of people
are like oh if you're an anarchist you
should live in the woods it's like
you know there's yankee fans who live in
boston uh it's my highest value but it's
not my only value
got it so the idea of okay so if it
wasn't us if it was in austin if it
wasn't in the states is there a place
where
you would say i'd feel good living in
xyz place or no
i don't i mean it's already gonna be
hard for me moving to austin you're not
a drive
well you're gonna have plenty of uber
and lyft over there to take care of you
you don't have to worry about it
sure but i i want to get a car it'll be
cool i get one of those 1980s cadillac's
which i always wanted as a kid
i keep in the garage because it's not
going to run but yeah i'm going to go
1980s cadillac i can see you in that
that's that's
they're cool they're so cool bensonhurst
so you know you know
bensonner's 44 so 42 so 42 1978 1970. so
so you were there were you know some of
the biggest most
powerful mobsters are from that city do
you have any stories with the mob or no
because that's a
mob central city you're in well i was
five
so of course i was hobnobbing with all
them no no but i can tell you
i mean even at 10 years old if you were
10 years old that would be 1986 that's
still the peak you're talking about
emmy carmine there's a lot of guys there
like
they kept the neighborhood very very
safe uh people always talk about mafia
neighborhoods mafia neighborhoods don't
really have much street crime
so they kept benzene is very very safe
what was funny to me
but as this the big takeaway was when
jersey shore came out
and everyone's like oh my god they
discovered guidos i'm like i grew up
with these people like how how is this
like
it's it'll be like having a tv show
where you're watching a goldfish tank
it's like
this is news to you this this is second
nature to what i grew up with so that
was kind of the environment
but bensonhurst has fallen now and it's
not italian anymore the italians all
went to jail or
jersey or long island that is true but
did you have still a great neighborhood
did you have any interactions with them
did you have any stories
did you any story i was a very sheltered
kid okay
got it so your parents uh kept you away
from all of that
oh yes for sure yeah i mean you're in
the capital of capital like like it's
oh yeah yeah i know uh uh it's it's what
south west brooklyn right is it
southwest brooklyn
southeast you think of bay ridge or
southwest okay south south east
brooklyn yeah okay got it yeah because i
think
i can give you a list of names of people
that i think came out of there okay
oh it's a huge list if you go on the
wikipedia it's insane it's a huge list
of people that
there's old the bronx too those old
ethnic neighborhoods in new york city
the amount of talent that came out of
them uh people don't even realize it's
just
there's such breeding grounds for you
know you have the immigrants then you
have the kid
who like is talented and now has the
opportunity to make something himself
it's
it's a remarkable american success story
and by the way this is why i have such
contempt
for people like de blasio cuomo because
every immigrant family who came here
and opened a stereotypical laundromat
fruit stand they were the first ones to
lose their lifelong goals and savings
uh whereas target and walmart are doing
just fine so so you so i thought for
sure you'd be a diehard dublastia fan i
i thought for sure you'd be like a cuomo
fan i mean i thought you'd have like
instead they should be in gib they
should be gitmo governor if you go to
governors to gitmo.com you get the
shirts
so so good question i asked this
question and i asked it
wait i don't understand how would an
anarchist be a fan of a mayor or
governor it's called sarcasm and i was
hoping you would
it's called it's called irony and you
were bad at it it's called sarcasm and
you missed it so
um so let me ask you as far as uh
as far as your biggest concern i asked
this from a lot of people i said what
do you think is your biggest concern we
got a lot of different things that's
going on you know we had we went from
obama to trump to
biden we go back a year ago streets
riots protesting
businesses we're seeing videos of a guy
with a you know 16 17 you know running
around with an m16
and we saw some weird stuff in the last
12 months
what is your biggest concern today we
have biden as a president kamado as a vp
trump's been banned facebook's not going
to return to band for a couple of years
twitter's not going to do that
we're in a very interesting time we're
living in to the point where
you're getting bill maher and people
like russell brand to start
jon stewart just like questioning the
fact that this was a man-made virus just
three months ago if that would have been
said on stephen colbert
they would have been banned their show
would have been banned but today it's
like going back to it so
what do you see as your biggest concern
today in america
those are all wonderful things in this
not all of them if it's
really great if you have an entity
whether it's
a girlfriend boyfriend or the media in
it can you imagine like you're dating
someone and she tells you for a year
baby i'm loyal baby i'm loyal baby i'm
loyal
and then you find the photographs of her
with some dude she's never going to be
able to unring that bell even if you
guys work it out
that will still always be that this is
not the person i thought
this is something she's capable of so to
have the media
which for decades had a monopoly on
public discourse in this country
until you had talk radio then you had
cable news
like starting with cnn i think in 1980
uh now you have social media
when you have these outlets like cnn
fox new york times insisting that
they're telling you the truth with the
straight face
and then it all collapses very quickly
when jon stewart
who's not exactly some kind of alt-right
conservative republican
is saying here's the thing let's suppose
john
i don't remember exactly what he said
but let's suppose he's wrong
the idea that we shouldn't be discussing
for future reference man-made viruses
how we would handle it what it would
look like if it got out
is insane that was what they were having
us
banned for and you are never going to be
able to regain the trust of the
population
you asked me earlier how we get to
anarchism this is how
the people who are in positions of
ostensible authority
demonstrate through their own depravity
of malfeasance
that not only are they mistaken which
they're gonna be
which you're gonna be which i'm gonna be
a lot but
they don't care and they're going to
continue
uh with these uh mistakes they're not
mistakes i think they're just blatant
lies and shutting down our conversations
it is very very hard if you're if your
brand is truth and trust and you've been
demonstrated
to be dishonest and untrustworthy to get
people to return to your brand i think
it's
very asymmetric in that regard how do
they how do they keep existing though
how do they keep
inertia how do they keep existing how do
they keep
being around and relevant and still
getting the eyeballs that they're
getting obviously i know
they're i know all the numbers who's
down who's up all that stuff
how are they still as relevant today and
i'm talking specifically media
yeah it's it's inertia if you look at
that friend you just mentioned
the one who gained 80 pounds i'm just
going to use him as shorthand i don't
mean him specifically
but if he's grown up you know watching
cbs at the dinner table with mom and dad
he's never going to
he doesn't want the choice he's like
this is something my parents watched
it's innocuous it's not upsetting me i
am learning the information i
am the person to screen seems very
respectable and smart
i'm just going to stick with this for
the you know the rest of my life so for
that population the blue pill
people they're they're not going to
change what i care about
are the people from all sides of the
political aisle and those of us who
reject politics entirely
who are capable of critical thoughts be
like oh these are really nefarious
malevolent
actors the the agencies and we have to
find ways to both mitigate their
power and to create alternative paths to
information
than going through them because at the
very least even if there were angels
they're still filtering the information
that i might otherwise find of use
and any filter as you have a tech
background knows you're going to be
letting in things you don't want
and you're going to be keeping out
things that you do this basic ab
test so uh that is something i think
it's very healthy what are signs that
you think we're going in the direction
of anarchy
what are signs um like people getting
sick of it
i'll give you i'll give one example the
fact that this is something i never
imagined in a million years
you know like if you sat me down in 2018
and gave me a list of 10 um
which would you pick and rank them in
order this would be number 10 by far
the fact that conservatives are now
skeptical of the police
is something i would have thought three
years ago was unimaginable
and now you see the i've never seen any
group
on any issue shift as quickly and
violently
as conservatives who i thought were a
lost cause after what they saw in 2020
are like wait a minute
these cops aren't necessarily my friends
they're taking orders from the state
which could be a good thing or a bad
thing and and who are you seeing saying
that
conservatives all over social media it's
shocking who what do you mean who give
me names who
uh the people the federalists people who
are just average citizens
uh you see it on the daily wire i mean
these are like
really mainstream drank the kool-aid
places in many cases
conservatives that are saying that the
police is
controlled by the government and they're
not worried about the police
conservative no they are they are
worried about the police before it used
to be back the blue that the cops are
your friends they have a tough job
now you see things like in belgium an
old man in a public park getting beaten
on the head with a baton by a cop on
horseback
it becomes very hard to defend and
that's another big difference by the way
you asked earlier about a russian
upbringing versus an american
uh the idea that cops are heroic is
almost
exclusively an american concept it
simply doesn't exist uh in eastern
europe
so so you partially are uh uh in
favor of defunding the police i'm in
favor of abolishing the government
police
monopoly uh defunding the police seems
like it could become a lot of problems
because you're
the same police who make the population
disarmed
are also not going to be doing anything
to uh
prevent the crimes that they're
fomenting so you end up getting the
worst of both worlds
last thing here before we wrap up voting
no you've never voted tell me why
i have voted i don't believe in voting
okay i read somewhere that says you
never voted i don't know where i read
that said you never voted so
tell me tell me why you don't believe in
voting uh i don't think
anyone has the right to represent me
other than on a specific issue
or a certain context like my accountant
or my lawyer or my doctor
you know and remember you said earlier
the first thing you asked me goes can
you give me the elevator pitch for
anarchism i said you do not speak for me
there you go
donald trump does not speak for me joe
biden does not speak for me uh
governor cuomo and mayor de blasio do
not speak for me no matter how wonderful
people they each individual may be or
how bright
which is saying something and how to
help like so
so you uh you don't work for anybody you
have your own pl
you're you're you're pro you're an
independent contractor i'm assuming
right right
right you get paid through the books you
write the speaking engagements you do
the invitations you get
that's how you're making your money
currently right now right right
right right so so so interesting so
in a in an environment of building a
company building a business
in a anarchy environment how do you see
the structure of a business do you see
the same exact way where there shouldn't
be a ceo presidency of osu no i think it
would
i don't know if it would be the same
exact way because you would have the
market would have innovation and right
now
you know what we have is you have many
different structures for businesses
so there's not absolutely no free
society you would have
different types of business different
structures what i would bet
is that there would be a lot less of hr
uh
you know having control in putting forth
the regime's ideas into every
corporation
i don't disagree because i do think
sometimes uh too much of the regulation
is getting in the way of uh
running the businesses i see that every
day myself but it's not only the
regulations that the people hr are
usually very mediocre people and this is
their
chance to kind of promulgate their
ideology into an unsuspecting population
there's a part of it that i'll tell you
what what uh what happened yesterday
yesterday i went to get my global entry
card i don't know if you've gotten yours
or not got not yet so i had it for 10
years and then boom i missed an
appointment my
somehow some way i missed the
appointment we paid everything boom took
a year for me to get it so i haven't had
my tsa free four years so
yesterday i'm driving up there to go get
it done now i'm ready i got interrupted
i'm sorry
do you think it's reasonable to wait a
year for something like this are you
kidding me like you have to wait for me
to make my point so
so rather than being a dictator give me
a minute here let me explain myself come
on but i want to be a dictator stop
maybe just tell us you want to dictate
us on what to do and i think secretly
inside that's what you want
but but so i go to tsa pre my assistant
calls
she said hey pat i talked to them
they're really being very
uh annoyed with me i'm like let me just
see what happens here i'm 20 minutes
late i walk in
are you bet david i am yes ma'am i'm so
sorry for being late
why are you late why did you she's
berating me
right and i'm sitting there i'm like man
i'm so sorry let me tell you what
happened
i don't care what happened come here i
can't believe we even take you're lucky
we're taking you
so at this point in my mind i'm going to
i have two options
i can sit there and snap at this woman
and give her all the argument that i got
and i still have to go to clear only and
i can do clear on tsa pre
i probably want tsa pre because there's
a lot of benefits to it
and if i go online and i complain on
yelp about what they did at global entry
who the hell gives a [ __ ]
nobody does right yeah so i go in and
i'm saying that this lady
is disrespecting me nonstop i go to the
other lady
why'd you miss your appointment why'd
you so the second lady and i said i said
ma'am i'm so sorry here you go
you almost feel like you have to
apologize because there's no level of
accountability
at the end right i'm leaving i said
ma'am i tell you i uh she says
make sure in five years you don't miss
your appointment i said ma'am in five
years
i promise you i'll be here on time and i
look forward to seeing you you will
never see me here again
i'm like okay are you like leaving this
job or something no if i know you're
coming i'm intentionally not going to
come then i'm like
this just crossed the line right now i'm
like okay no problem hey thank you so
much all the best when i walk in i'm
like i'm just walking out of this place
before they change their minds i've done
the fingerprinting everything
i leave and i say this is exactly why no
one in the government ever gives you
good service because they don't have to
who to help kim jong this was an issue
actually north korea kim jong-il was
complaining about this but let's look a
different way yeah
uh i'm not saying this this woman
wouldn't exist in a free society
what i'm saying is just like your credit
score you would have
five three agencies that could clear pat
to go on the planes
they would probably be more stringent
than the tsa because their reputation
they're competing
so they want to make sure that they
don't let muhammad through
and how many times have people gone to a
restaurant
or a hairdresser or a bookstore and been
spoken to like that by a fellow adult
especially and and here's the thing
that's most important
you knew damn well there's nothing you
can do
if my waiter talks to me like that my
hairdresser the book i
i could talk to their boss i could go
karen absolutely
but when it's a government right you
have no outlet now
what happens when you have a cop who
doesn't want to investigate
or or any other situation you have no
options where if you had competing
security at the very least
you would have people treat you as a
customer with a modicum of civility and
respect
here's the thing she could have said
here's something she could have said
very easy to you that you would have
liked
you know what i'm trying to do a hard
job there's a lot of people here
it's pretty disrespectful that you
showed up late and you'd be like you're
right i'm sorry yeah
and then it then it'll be a perfectly
fine uh situation
she's getting off because this very very
low status
piece of crap is now in a position of
power over somebody
and she's going to flex that power to
the ultimate
of her ability you talked about your
uncle you just met her
that is your uncle the hypothetical
uncle now she's in a position of power
so what i want to do is to not have her
have a monopoly
and therefore limit although i can't
eliminate it can't make her cease to
exist
her capacity you're it ruined your date
so much you're still thinking about it
and for what you showed up late and
here's my here's my
and you're paying her here's my opinion
my opinion is
on the jail the same thing would happen
anarchy
same thing would happen you know it's
not true but tell me every other
industry
what other industry have you been spoken
to like that i don't i don't on the
customer service side
yes you're 100 right but on the
okay so let me ask you this question
what do you think about laws of monopoly
what are you doing no no
you're shifting goals
you did you just made a claim you said
under anarchy
this would be the same it would be
under anarchy i'm going to help you i've
got to finish asking my question go
forward
what other industry which is currently
not a government monopoly
have you been spoken to like that with
any kind of regularity if at all
if the business has a monopoly they can
do that let me explain to you what i
mean by that let me explain to you i i
allowed you to finish so here's my year
you didn't answer me give me an example
if you
allow me to answer that i'll tell you
i'm in an area if i'm i've lived all
over i've been in every state in america
40 states in america i've been i lived
in the army i've been all over it i've
lived in 20 different places in my
lifetime
if i'm in an area where
i'm in a dry county where there's only
one liquor store and i'm 40 miles away
and i know
if i don't get the beer from this guy he
can jerk me around and say
screw you you don't want to go drive the
40 miles in those types of situations
i've experienced that
now again it's it's it's it's going to
be
90 more times on the government type of
a setting than this would be
but i think on the one law like on this
guy who has a monopoly in that area what
am i going to say i'm going to say you
know what you're right man i just want
the beer
i'm going to charge you a dollar more no
problem i'm going to buy this beer from
excel i don't have any other choice i
got to buy it from you
you do have a choice my only choice is
what what is my choice
you have seamless and then you have to
interact with him in the future
you're right but if i live close to him
and the closest other place is 40 miles
away
who the hell wants to drive that 40
miles away you don't have to drive 40
miles away you hire someone
to go to the beer store for you so you
get the beer and you don't have to deal
with the resources you're assuming
you're gonna have the resources
if you have enough money to buy beer you
have enough money to pay five bucks
there's someone together
that's not gonna be five bucks that gas
is gonna be a lot more and especially in
that environment he's not going to the
40 mile of place he's going to the one
close to you
he's going to the one close to me you
there's this let's put
let's hold on this is the only liquor
store on earth yeah but but anyway
a guy who has that kind of an attitude
the guy's
the guy who has that kind of an attitude
he's got that attitude towards everybody
not just me
just like this lady at psa pre she's got
that kind of an attitude towards
everybody
what i'm saying is let's suppose this is
the only liquor store on earth right
you could if you want that beer but you
don't want to deal with this a-hole
you hire someone to go to the store
across the street
buy you the beer and deliver to you that
peace of mind is worth to you more
than it is the amount of exchange would
be to hire that person
you don't have that option with the
government monopoly you have to go
you're not our
and look at that woman in the face you
have to
have that interaction whereas with
seamless or any other innovation
you'd have the option even if he has a
monopoly on the entire planet of not
dealing with that individual or speaking
to the cro i mean
this this is a i'm uh i'm i'm 100
i'm a free enterprise guy there and i'm
100 there with you i do fully agree with
that my only concern
and one more thing in all seriousness it
depends on the size of the of the
location of course but no one would
dispute that if there's a big enough
population
and there's one liquor store and the
guy's really a piece of crap
and there's another liquor store where
they make it a good experience
that is one very easy way to compete it
is
and probably what would end up leading
happening is over the next year two
years three years somebody's eventually
going to want to open up a shop to
compete with the guy and put him out of
business
and become the great equalizer you're
right i or he'll hi all here hire a hot
chick
because it's annoying for him dealing
with the beer people and be like you
know what i'm just going to own this
business you deal with these late people
yeah but eventually you have to know
that anybody that's got
the monopoly laws the monopoly laws on
the businesses when a guy gets too
powerful
it is very tough to compete with
somebody when they get too much money
and they're too powerful
that would be a concern if someone has
way too much power because
they can gobble up like you know i get a
call one time from ftc
one of the insurance technology
companies is getting very big they're
about to buy out the last one if they
buy it they control the marketplace you
don't have a choice
the guy was negotiating with me for the
longest time from the standpoint of
everybody uses this software i'm the
only one in town
the license costs you half a million
dollars and per user you have to pay
this much money
he's telling me this what do i do again
this is a point back to you
the point is i go to the smaller guy as
i'm coming to you because i'm going to
go to the smaller guy
when i go to the smaller guy his
software isn't as good as this
guy he doesn't have the kind of support
that he has he cannot do it as fast as
this guy does
he cannot do any of that stuff guess
what happens five years later
this guy ends up buying this guy right
fpc calls me and says hey we're buying
this guy what do you want to do about
them like i'm not even getting on this
call they talked to my executive team
eventually the ftc prevented this cell
from happening
if he does gobble them up michael i'm in
the world of business every day i mean
i don't have any leverage on
negotiations with this guy anymore he's
winning
the reason this is a situation is
because these giant corporations
lobby and work with the state to create
extremely high barriers to entry
in terms of competition so in a free
society that is one
yeah that is one that's a major part and
it's and
in a free society where it would be much
easier to enter any
any field this would not tend to happen
what you're discussing is a historical
fallacy
there's never been a case where one
business gobbled up every other because
let's suppose i want to gobble up
bitcoin for example
as soon as i buy some or as soon as i
buy a company the ones who are left
are going to be worth that much more and
it becomes asymptotic
so even if you have someone who has five
percent the market
if this guy is charging uh so-called
monopoly rates of half a million
and i'm charging 250 000 and some loss
of functionality
i'm still carving a space for myself in
the market
yeah in a in a so so the challenge with
a lot of these arguments michael
is we only paint the picture of a
perfect world
none of this is perfect i'm saying he
has less functionality and cheaper
that's not perfect i do agree it is less
functionality and cheaper you're right
and
the company how's that perfect uh no
it's not it's not it's perfect it's
they're still gonna be the people who
are my experience i'm kind of coming out
of high school
and i'm going in my life to to kind of
choose what i want to do my life
i had friends of mine who were driven by
power
friends of mine who were driven by dude
leave me alone don't buy i had friends
of mine
you better do this i'm like dude what is
the matter with you man just relax kick
back
so i had friends of mine that went into
the space of wanting to
impose power to you that was their way
of controlling you you better do this
because you know i'm
gonna say okay great and then there were
some friends like just kind of leave me
alone i'm gonna go make my millions
don't bother me i'm gonna live my own
life for whatever reason these guys
despise these guys sure whatever reason
these guys are not a fan of
these guys that make the money now let
me flip it here's the problem
here's the problem just again give me
your argument on this one destroy my
argument on wherever i'm going here
so this guy and this guy are not the
same people right
right this guy's power comes from what a
very
powerful institution above them called
the government right
right now watch what happens to this guy
he is like leave me alone let me go live
my life
but this guy's gonna have four kids one
of his kids
is going to become extremely lazy let's
just say i'm just throwing it out there
sure one of his kids is like do you know
who my dad is do you know who my dad is
same role there's almost like a
government mentality
do you know my father's do you know what
i could do to you like that type of
environment
sure this guy ends up dying he's worth
100 million bucks
25 25 25 25. 25 is given to one guy who
has the same personality as this guy now
they're equals
they're the same they're not equals
they're they're not equals in a sense of
attitude like they're both driven by
power they're not equals
but the attitude and the mindset of you
better or else it's that you better or
else mentality
when people like those who are driven by
power
get money and they have the you better
or else mentality
i think history tells us they have a
tendency of destroying a lot of things
what are your thoughts okay
you work with very many successful
people i do
i i can't it's hard for me to wrap my
head around the
claim that if someone inherits 25
million dollars
they're really in a position to do much
of anything that's not that much money
uh in terms of changing society it's not
about the i'm not
fine fine let's suppose 200 let's
suppose 250 million
the point is no matter how much money
okay okay hold on
we can go to trillions at at a certain
point this becomes a problem but let's
suppose
i agree let's suppose bill gates bill
gates has
very limited power to impose his will
on the population he gets his power
because he's selling a product
that people are comfortable buying if he
behaved in depraved ways i don't mean
just
political abuse people dislike but just
really kind of six harvey weinstein
he will be not only driven out of his
industry but my biggest concern
is the status quo where bill gates can
get the president on the phone
in a second and that person has armies
has the
ftc he has all of the senate at his
disposal
because lobbyists cost him nothing so
all of these things that you're
describing
all these things you described as a
concern are a concern
in any society when you have rich
powerful people
and they want to impose their will and
everybody else how do you prevent it
and for me my answer is the best way to
prevent it
is to decentralize power as much as
possible so that the
malevolent bill gates can't just seize
that one institution
here's the thing if he bought the new
york times tomorrow he
will have influence he will have
relevance he's still not going to be a
hitler or stalin not even close
if he was elected president he still
wouldn't be a hitler or stalin not even
close or a senator or supreme court
judge no individual in a free society
has anywhere near the power of a
dictator even if
a small [ __ ] country we we are on
the same page they're coming from a guy
who lived in iran for 10 years
of course lived in germany at a refugee
camp for two years having
been in the u.s military and seeing a
bunch of different people i don't
disagree i think monopolies are a
byproduct of the help of a government
it's very hard to have it without it
and we all know what happened when a lot
of these bigger companies decided to
choose their headquarters
for whatever reason they all choose
headquarters near dc dmv
of virginia because that allows them to
buy lobbyists and all this other stuff
and they'd have a choice because if if i
don't hire a lobbyist my competitors
will and they're going to write the
rules
and they're like i don't blame them yeah
and you'll hear them say things like i
think we need to raise taxes i'm like
what happened how come you know because
they're not worried about taxes they're
worried about laws
regulation they're willing to support
politicians increasing the taxes because
they're barely paying taxes they don't
take money out of the world they've
already made their money
but a two or three additional loss gives
them so much power over everybody
but also they want they want the taxes
to be raised because if i'm starting out
and i don't have that much 100 in the
bank it's going to be a lot harder for
me for that first year to muddle through
whereas if i've got my bank and i pay
that one percent which i don't even have
to pay because i have a good accountant
it's it's win-win for me and i get to be
the good guy we talked about it today on
the podcast where buffett is like
i'm not paying enough taxes don't do it
forget about go ahead and write the
check
you're seeing it at 89 years old you
know your age your late 80s you
why don't you say that at 14 years old
when you wanted to be the best investor
of all time
rather than saying that as an 18 89 year
old like you're hurting it for the other
guys
to want to come up and compete anyways
and also you could pay more if you want
you could you don't
have the choice we have the choice
absolutely
michael i've enjoyed it we went 90
minutes it was a lot of fun
i enjoyed talking to you i enjoyed
getting deeper into that
uh crazy wild crystal clear in your own
mind brain
and uh hopefully we'll do this again
buddy appreciate you
i i hope people uh go to
anarchisthandbook.com and
hear about it at length instead of my
off the cuff
but this is a lot of fun i'm going to
put the link to your book and your
website below and they can go find you
there
awesome thank you so much take care
anarchy do you believe in it do you
think it could work he sounded very
convincing or
do you think it's got to be a small
little region where they're everybody
that's kind of living together they
share common values and principles
but even with that would somebody
eventually become way too ambitious to
say i feel i
should be leading this entire place and
convince others to do so i don't know i
want to hear your thoughts comment below
and if you enjoyed these two interviews
i got two others that you may enjoy one
of them is with jarome brook
the former chairman of iran institute
which was similar dialogue
or with john perkins former economic
hitman
yes he was an economic hitman going to
countries
negotiating with the leader of that
country and then eventually taking over
territory oil or other things if you
enjoy that kind of conversation click
over here
and if you're not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye
[Music]
you